all right well thank you it's always
great to be back here at Berkeley with
the old friends and new friends so I
chose a provocative or even oxymoronic
cooking title quantum supremacy is the
most quintessentially definitionally
useless thing in the world and I'll tell
you about it and also about applications
of it okay so you know and I know that
this term supremacy you know is getting
a lot of pushback and and complaints and
suggestions that we need we need a
better term
Simon Benjamin recently suggested to me
the term quantum in imitability
inability to imitate classically if you
can pronounce that you're welcome to use
that instead I also you know from from
John Martinez's talk this morning I got
the idea that we should just say this is
the you know the quantum hello world
which is just hello Hilbert space right
so okay we could we could also call it
that so yeah so the first part of the
talk will be based on joint work with Li
G Chen which is at the CCC conference in
the second part of the talk is not
published yet okay so so what is this
quantum supremacy so you know the way
that I described it for years was that
you know it is targeting what for me has
always been the number one application
of quantum computing okay more important
apparently then you know optimization
than code breaking even in quantum
simulation and that is just for you know
Gil Kauai and for these other people who
come to my blog and say that quantum
computing is impossible for them to
admit that they were wrong okay you know
or you know or or if if hypothetically
they were to turn out to be right well
then that's even more exciting so you
know great but you know we basically
we are trying to you know I guess for
the first time maybe really
experimentally test you know whether
quantum mechanics violates the extended
church-turing thesis whether it lets us
do some tasks that cannot be efficiently
classically simulated or let's say that
is hard to simulate and not merely for
reasons of sort of our system being
complicated not being well characterized
enough the constant factors being large
but actually for reasons of asymptotic
complexity
you know arising from the exponential T
of quantum states okay so you know and
you know what's exciting as we all know
is that this might actually be
achievable in well you know I mean you
know I I like to say when when an
experimentalist tell me one year I
figure you know maybe three years maybe
four years you know but you know but
that but but that doesn't you know that
doesn't that doesn't translate to
infinity years right so it's you know in
some in some l1 years right that you
know maybe you know yeah we will have we
will have 72 Cupid chips you know or
we'll have you know either in
superconducting may you know conceivably
also in entrapped ions and you know that
will really be fully programmable and we
could do things like put random quantum
circuits on them okay and you know I
would always say at the beginnings of my
talks obviously this is not you know
this is you completely useless for
anything other than proving the point
that you know quantum gives you a
speed-up but you know but that that's
the main thing I care about anyway so so
let's just try to try to achieve this
milestone you know and then after that
worry about you know doing something
that's useful alright so so so if this
is your goal you know to to just
demonstrate you know you can solve
something that is you know what say
we're as confident as possible is
classically hard then something that
that many of us realized around a decade
ago is that there are a lot of
advantages to switching
decision problems so you know problems
with a single right answer the you know
traditional thing we talked about in
complexity theory two sampling problems
okay your problems with you know many
possible right answers or but say where
the goal is just to output a sample
you know exactly or approximately from
some target probability distribution
okay so actually the the the roots of
this go back to work in 2004 by a Touhou
Linda Vincenzo the sort of modern
Renaissance of this that sort of
connected the you know the hardness of
these sampling problems to the belief
that the polynomial hierarchy is
infinite I guess you know that was done
independently by Bremner Josa and
Shepard with their iqp model also by me
and Alix arkhipov with boson sampling
and since then we've discovered many
other models where you know what are the
the advantages of these types of things
first of all you know we again and again
find that we can solve these hard
sampling problems using devices that may
fall short of being universal quantum
computers right so they are not bqp
complete okay in many cases they're not
even universal for classical computing
right they just do this very limited
sampling task and yet it is something
that we can argue is classically hard
okay and actually second point is you
know if you just if all you care about
is confidence that a task is classically
hard I think that you know at least for
exact sampling problems we can be much
more confident that those are
classically hard then we are that
factoring for example is classically
hard right you know I would say if
there's a fast classical factoring
algorithm well you know that would that
would collapse much of the world's
digital economy but as far as we know it
would not collapse the polynomial
hierarchy right which to a which to a
complexity theorist is the much more
impressive collapse okay so so so I'm
not going to go through the arguments
about you know why these you know a fast
classical algorithm to solve these exact
sampling problems you know would
collapse the polynomial hierarchy first
of all because you know I mean I mean
many of you have already already have
already seen them and for those who
haven't it's not going to be very
relevant for for this talk but you know
this is the bottom line is that you know
we can get evidence that these sampling
problems are hard based on very
extremely basic conjectures in
complexity theory right you know like
really fundamental kind of structural
things and furthermore you know with we
know we could hopefully solve these
problems with near future technologies
like you know noisy intermediate scale
or NIST quantum computers to use John
Prescott's term okay you know merely we
give up you know I thought you know at
least you know until some months ago on
any practical applications of any of
this and and also you know it's not
obvious how to easily verify the results
that seems to require doing an
exponential time classical computation
and we'll we'll come back to that point
later okay so let me just jump straight
to you know the particular instance of
you know these a sampling based quantum
supremacy that you know where we're
hoping we'll be done in in in O of 1
years in the future which is sort of
sampling the output distributions of
random quantum circuits ok and this is
you know the as you heard this morning
in John Martinez's talk you know the
group at Google is you know has has set
this as a goal and you know I hope
others will will also try this the basic
idea is you know we generate a quantum
circuit at random from some natural
ensemble we won't worry too much about
the details but for example if our
qubits were arranged in a 2d lattice of
size square root of n by square root of
n then we could imagine you know what is
natural to that of architecture is
look at spatially local you know nearest
neighbor to qubit gates so we would
imagine just having a whole bunch of
layers of those gates that we choose
randomly from some set we arrange them
in some number of layers how many layers
well clearly we need enough layers that
every qubit can influence every other
one so at least square root of n of them
you know beyond that probably the more
the better okay but you know we'll come
back later through the relation between
the number of layers and the difficulty
of simulating the thing classically
right the number of layers you can do
will of course be determined by the
coherence of your qubits and then the
fidelity of your gates okay okay and so
you pick a circuit you know of the
suitable depth at random you know and
then we fix it let's say okay and then
we imagine taking that circuit applying
it to the all zero initial state and
then just measuring the result in the
you know each qubit in the zero one
basis now that gives us a sample from
some probability distribution over n bit
strings all right you know in principle
we could repeat this over and over and
get many samples from the same
distribution okay so so imagine that we
do that right we get let's say T
independent samples from this
distribution X 1 up to X T and as John
stressed this morning this distribution
is not the uniform distribution that
that's easy to sample from okay it is a
distribution with a very large entropy
but not maximal entropy right it has
little bumps in it because of you know
quantum interference right some outcomes
are somewhat likelier than others okay
and those bumps are really the thing
that we're going to be looking for okay
now you know a common misconception is
that well you would have to repeat the
experiment an exponential number of
times in order to you know characterize
this whole distribution in fact you
don't need to do that you can just
repeat the experiment
a small number of times let's say you
know at tbo of one right so just collect
a fairly small number of samples and
then the idea is that we're more apply
some sort of statistical test to check
whether those samples are consistent
with being drawn from our hard
distribution three it's not horror and
Amit is the output distribution of this
circuit see right and in fact it can't
be hard on them because C is a
polynomial size circuit in many
important respects it is like a [ __ ]
random distribution and you know we
often use that fact yeah all right all
right just to be clear the same thing as
a randomly chosen point in the simplex
of distributions no nice and my answer
will be the same as my answer to read it
is not horror anthem because it is the
output distribution of this circuit C
which has polynomial size we don't have
nearly enough gates to have reached a
random point in the simplex all right
yes in in many respects such as the
distribution of the histogram of
probabilities the answer is yes it will
behave like that you know in in some
cases we've actually been able to prove
that and even you know for the for the
statements of that form that we can't
prove we know it by way of MATLAB okay
so okay just flat flat
random in the sense of Euclidean
geometry you threw a dart at this
employee well it-it-it axilla it acts
like that in many respects yes but I
guess the problem right for the
particular circuit see it's just a
single distribution D sub C as we would
vary over all the possible C's of the
appropriate size we get a whole
collection of distributions this you
know collection of distributions can be
analogized in some ways to the haar
measure over distributions or sorry the
random point on the probability simplex
rather okay but you know but but it's
but it's clearly not that it doesn't
have enough nearly enough parameters to
be then okay okay so now let me explain
what you do okay so you take these
samples with you know which there might
be a fairly small number say a thousand
or something and we all we do is we
check whether they solve some you know
whether they pass some test so for the
computer scientists you can think of it
as we are asking you know do they solve
some relational problem right do they
satisfy some relation and the relation
will have to do with these X uh buys
that we saw being assigned a large you
know most of them being assigned large
probabilities by this distribution D sub
C okay so Legion and I called this the
heavy output generation or hog problem
okay there you know so so in an example
so um what the Google Group prefers to
use is a test involving cross-entropy
I think that that also works fine for
for what I'm going to talk about here
okay it the type of test that is a
simpler to think about for our purposes
is just some kind of threshold intest
where for example we could ask you know
do at least two-thirds of these excise
have a greater than median probability
like probability greater than natural
log 2 over 2
the end okay or you know you could also
look at the sum of all the probabilities
of these and ask is it at least T over 2
to the N times some constant like you
know 1.5 or something yes it is yes I
mean you could also vary it and then all
again do a test involving like just all
of them together you know each one with
its distribution right that would also
make sense but for now I'm just assuming
it's the same circuit that's right so
this is this is very much a test that is
designed as I said for NIST quantum
computers okay you know with what's the
so so this is classical verification
you'll notice that well I wrote it right
here it takes exponential time to do it
with your classical computer which means
you know yeah you could do it with you
know 60 cubits you know even seventy
cubits right with you know according to
the recent alibaba paper anyway what all
right okay well let's say with 60 48
well you know it depends how much you're
willing to spend right all right all
right so 48 okay all right fine so you
know you go up to the largest number
such that you can still do verification
you know but the point is that the
verification can be done but it is
expensive okay you can see that you know
it takes you days to do it whereas the
actual sampling process hopefully you
know was done in a very small fraction
of a second okay so and it's kind of
that difference that word that we're
interested in here okay but it is true
that we do not know for these types of
experiments we do not know a polynomial
time classical algorithm to verify the
results I mean you know in principle
there are ways to do such things you
know once you've built a more powerful
quantum computer with fault tolerance
and so
but you know we it is a it is a
fantastic problem how you do that in the
nasarah
so okay and then you know you publish
your circuit you challenge skeptics to
generate samples passing your test in a
reasonable amount of time you know now
you know of course you could just do
that have it be purely empirical but you
know as complexity theorists we would
like to do better than you know then
saying you know you know we'd like to
say something more about this then you
all rule seems ordered to me alright so
you know so that's okay so so look so
this is this is what the distribution
looks like right we already talked about
this right that the the distribution
looks like a rant you know a random
point on the probability simplex in the
sense that the the number of
probabilities you know the number of
outputs that have probability say at
least B times 2 to the N goes like e to
the minus B right that's an e to the
minus B fraction of the outputs okay
answer but you're never going to see
anything with probability 0 so if you
look at what I should actually be
observing if the experiment is done
correctly the probability should be
distributed like this right if I was
just sampling completely at random then
the probabilities would be distributed
like that right and we could you know we
can do statistics to see the difference
between these things we can look for the
speckle pattern as yeah as John puts it
okay so now you know under what sort of
assumption can we actually show that
this is a hard problem for a classical
computer right well notice you know we
we're asking for something strong okay
we want to speak say first of all you
know not merely that it is hard to
exactly sample from this probability
distribution right if we just wanted
that then that's you know we we will we
know how to do that right we know the
tools for arguing that okay we like to
say at a minimum that it is hard to even
a prop for a classical computer to even
approximately sample from that
distribution right already there you
know that you have to stick your neck
out and
stronger conjectures at present
that's what arkhipov and i had to do
with boson sampling that is also what
Bremner Josa and shepard had to do with
the iqp model right so that already
requires a stronger conjecture but here
we want something stronger still okay we
want that for a classical adversary it
is hard for them to do anything
whatsoever that solves the hog problem
okay that passes that statistical test
regardless of whether they're actually
sampling from approximately the right
distribution okay so you know so we know
what we know matter what they're doing
right even if it's the terminus thing
that you should just not be able to pass
this test we want to make that empirical
statement right so all right so - we can
get that you know if you know if you'll
give us a suitably strong hardness
assumption all right you know it's
always like that right you can get any
conclusion you want if you make a strong
enough assumption okay but you know but
this will not be tautological okay be a
quite because the you know this
assumption will not talk about the
hardness of a sampling problem or a
relation problem okay we'll just say
assume that there is no polynomial time
classical algorithm that given a random
quantum circuit say with n qubits and
with M gates M being large compared to n
which turns out to be very important
here you know that it will guess with
like a bias even slightly better than
random whether a given output amplitude
of this circuit is like larger or
smaller than say the median of all the
amplitudes okay that is our assumption
okay that you can't even do this with 2
to the minus n better probability than
random guessing and being a number of
qubits okay now you know this is a
little bit on the edge this conjecture
right and a way to say no and a way to
see that is that there is actually a
poly time classical algorithm that
guesses whether an amplitude is large or
small with this bias over random
guessing 1 over exponential in m the
number of gates ok this is why I said
the number of gates has to be
compared to the number of qubits okay
the way to do this is just to write the
amplitude you care about as a Fineman
some you know some of lots of
contributions and then just sample some
of them randomly this is good this will
work yeah this is good
okay so then you know a theorem that one
can prove or observe let's say is you
know if you assume that strong hardness
assumption then you know given a random
quantum circuit say there's no poly time
classical algorithm that even passes our
statistical test with high probability
okay the proof well I can fully put it
on this slide you know it's a reduction
okay the basic idea of the reduction is
well you know suppose that you had a
poly time classical algorithm that
passed our test that solved a Hogg
problem with a high probability then you
know we could use this to derive a
guessing algorithm because we could just
run the sampling procedure and see does
it output the you know the output that
we're that we care about you know if it
does then we guess okay so maybe it had
a larger amplitude and if not we guess
okay maybe it had a smaller amplitude
now that's a really bad guessing
algorithm in fact it only gives you a
bias of like 1 over exponential and N
better than random guessing but that is
enough to refute the strong hardness
assumption so you know given the
assumption yeah this kind of problem is
gonna be hard ok now I should mention
you know of course we would like
hardness of random circuit sampling
based on weaker complexity assumptions
there's a very nice recent progress in
this direction by Adam Boland at all in
this paper they're going to be a talk
about this later in the conference but
you know but basically they've they've
what lightning talk so they've shown
that the complexity situation for random
circuit sampling is sort of at least as
good as it is for boson sampling
essentially right they've shown that
it is you know to compute - exactly
compute a random amplitude in a random
quantum circuit is a sharpie hard
problem okay now to really get the start
getting the conclusions we want you
would need it to approximate a random
amplitude and a random quantum circuit
is start be hard and that kind of
statement we just don't know how to
prove yet neither with boson sampling
nor with random quantum circuits but at
least we have kind of parity between the
two models now because of this work okay
so then you know the other thing we did
is we G and I is that we made a
good-faith effort to try to refute our
strong hardness assumption you know
trust me okay which said you know what
are you know what are actually the best
classical algorithms for just simulating
a general quantum circuit with n qubits
and M gates you only think that was a
question that must have been studied to
death you know 20 plus years ago okay
but we noticed something that actually
was not known as far as we know about
this question okay would you know there
are two very different ways to simulate
a quantum circuit classically there's
first what I'll call the Schroedinger
approach okay which is if you store the
whole wave function in memory so that
takes lots and lots of memory but the
amount of time is not much worse than
the memory ready to to the end time to
to the end memory let's say don't just
do matrix vector multiplies okay second
approach I'll call the Fineman approach
okay and this is you just calculate the
amplitude you care about by summing over
all the contributions to it now this
approach is much much better in terms of
memory usage fact uses only a linear
amount of memory but the time that it
needs is now exponential in M the number
of gates rather than n the number of
qubits okay and that difference could be
enormous in the in the regime we're
talking about right you know you like
you you know if your Google you can do 2
to the 50 apparently but you know but
I'm gonna stick my neck out and say not
even Google can do 2 to the thousands
okay that's more that that is more than
a googol so this video okay
right so so so you know so system.this
raised an immediate question which is is
there a simulation algorithm that
achieves the best of both worlds
that is that uses small memory but also
time that is merely exponential in n the
number of qubits okay and what we found
is that there almost is such an
algorithm okay so you know if I have a
quantum circuit say with n qubits and D
gates or even D layers of gates you know
so they're so stronger okay then I can
compute whichever transition amplitude I
want with polynomial and act as actually
linear in and in D memory so as good
memory as the Fineman approach and time
which is like D to the o of n okay the
number of the depth to the power of the
number of qubits okay and and
furthermore you can smoothly interpolate
between this algorithm and the
Schroedinger algorithm right so
basically with every halving of the map
so starting with the Schroedinger
algorithm let's say for every halving of
the memory that you have available you
can multiply the running time by a
factor of D and still simulate the thing
okay and the proof of it well for anyone
whose knows classical complexity theory
the proof is just savages theorem okay
it is a recursive divide and conquer
approach I we take our quantum circuit
just split it into two sub circuits say
with D over two layers each and then we
can take our amplitude and we can
rewrite it like this right this is just
a rewriting okay and then we recurse on
these guys we keep going you know I'm
almost you know embarrassed to present
something so simple okay but that's that
that is what it is okay and we you know
we do recursion we know we don't we keep
reusing the same memory you know and
then we we show that yeah you can do
better or even if your circuit is
nearest neighbor by using tensor Network
like methods you can take advantage of
that okay but this algorithm
you know you know is sort of worth
knowing about though it is it still does
not falsify our strong hardness
assumption why not well because in order
to falsify that you know you need to
guess particularly you know an amplitude
with like better you know
then chance probability right and so you
really want your amplitude written as a
simple sum of exponentially many
contributions right but this doesn't do
that
this writes your amplitude as a sum of
products of sums of products of and so
forth right in order to get this
efficiency it has to be more complicated
and so it doesn't seem to lead to the
guessing algorithm that would that would
falsify that sha okay but another thing
I should mention is that this type of
art you know the type of argument that
we made for a random circuit sampling
does not work for boson sampling or for
the iqp model and the reason is that
with those models there is not a
parameter analogous to the number of
gates that you can just keep increasing
you know larger and larger and that sort
of controls your you know advantage over
random guessing right you know so so so
so there is something you know special
about having a sort of a more general
kind of quantum circuit for this
argument yeah because because this
instead of just writing a sum of
exponentially many terms we write it as
a sum of products of two things and then
we recursively evaluate these okay and
so we get a savings in time you know
again the fine men approached used for
to the M time this is using D to the o
of n all right so you can see that they
must be different because you know
writing times different okay so you know
what about errors you know of course you
know you know you have to imagine it
you'll have you know some bit flip
errors you know a good heuristic is that
if we had like K errors the variation
distance between the distribution that
we'll be sampling and the uniform
distribution which you know is something
that we don't want will decrease by a
factor that is exponential in K
right you know what that means in
practice is that you know you can handle
one bit flip error probably two bit flip
errors you know beyond that it already
starts getting dicey right so you know
from discussions with the Google people
I know that they are well aware of you
know just how demanding a technological
requirement this is you know to get the
error rate that low where of course we
don't yet have our correction to help us
do it and you know it will come down to
numbers you know as to you know how well
this can be achieved okay so as I said
the verification needs to be difficult
but not impossible and now I guess the
Bitcoin mining you might say you know
there are some nice recent papers but
ped not at all from IBM Chen it all from
Ali Baba okay actually uh
John tells me that a who doesn't believe
this we can maybe have a discussion
about it later but in any case what I
what I wanted to say is that the ability
to simulate these kinds of you know
numbers of qubits is not only does it
not sort of refute what we're trying to
do you have to be able to do it in order
to do it what we want to do right again
the classical simulation has to be
possible you know because we need it for
the verification you know it just has to
be much less efficient than doing the
actual quantum sampling okay so having
explained that hopefully I never you
know will here again someone you know
saying you know this this paper came out
showing you can simulate this this thing
classically and therefore quantum
sampling based quantum super amorously
is a sham okay I expect I'm never gonna
hear that again okay so so let me just
in a final part of the talk but you know
okay so so obviously these experiments
are completely useless you know as I
said in talks for years and years
because all they do is just give you a
whole bunch of bits that if the
experiment works our base are almost
completely random right and who needs
you know like that and who you know
these actually come from random.org okay
you know
but you know who who you know but who
needs a bunch of random bits all right
well you know then you know it actually
occurred to some people that uh actually
there are people who who who need random
bits and then and that can be useful
okay to have you know to actually have
sort of cryptographically certified
randomness right and there are sort of
two types of uses of this if the
randomness is secret known only to you
or only to you and your friend then you
can use it for cryptographic private
keys and in fact you need you know you
better have randomness if you're
generating a cryptographic keys okay but
all there are also many uses for public
randomness which we could just be
announced over the internet and known to
everybody
okay the obvious example would be a
lottery right also deciding which
precincts to audit in an election also
you know the setting the parameters for
crypto systems you know in a way that
everyone can believe that they were not
backdoored various zero-knowledge
protocols and the public randomness and
then you know the proof of stake
cryptocurrencies so the ones that are
trying to you know get the advantages of
Bitcoin without using like 1% of the
world's electricity right you know one
of the ways that you know one of the
ideas for doing it is that you know each
time you know whenever each each coin
that you have gives you the right to
enter a lottery to add a new block to
the blockchain okay but then you have to
run this lottery in a way that everyone
agrees is secure okay so you might say
that this problem is trivial to solve
quantumly here's a quantum circuit that
solves it right I hope you agree the
output of the circuit is a random bit
right or you know or take like just some
radioactive you know you know some
nuclear material you know that you you
got from Kim Jong or whatever and you
know and put some you know and have a
Geiger counter right okay but the
problem is well what if your hardware
was back to work right so so we we know
we would like as we were discussing
yesterday a device
source of randomness meaning that we
would like some way of generating random
bits where you don't have to trust
anything about the construction of the
hardware right the hardware could have
been designed by your worst enemy you're
just going to submit challenges to the
hardware get responses back and then
verify those responses and the only part
you're gonna you know you'll need to
trust is a deterministic classical
computation that will verify the
response is okay that can obviously
never be backdoored by anything so you
know it's fine to trust that all right
so you know so this is actually a
research direction that was you know
pursued in a sequence of beautiful works
over the last decade and people
basically figured out how to get you
know sort of certified randomness
generation using experiments that
violate the Bell inequality right so you
know this the line was initiated by Cole
Beck and Renner and then continued by
Perot neo at all Vaz irani and vidiq
Kudrin and UN Miller and she large
fraction of them here okay and the so
the basic idea is you know you have
Alice and Bob play the CH SH game over
and over you assume that they're unable
to communicate with each other but they
do share entanglement and then you know
if they're able to win the CH SH game
you know a probability bounded above 3/4
then we can conclude more than just that
you know well they must have had
entanglement that you know that we know
that's in sometimes you know they could
not have known their outputs in advance
right there must be real entropy in
their outputs ok because otherwise to
coordinate everything would have
required faster-than-light communication
right which we've assumed that you know
they don't have or you know or
communication at any rate between them
okay so you know so you need a small
initial investment of randomness to just
generate the challenges to send to them
but the culmination of this work was to
show that with
even just a very very small initial seed
you can get a serve in on an unlimited
expansion in the number of random bits
that you have let's say you start with
10,000 random bits you know that you got
from somewhere I don't know where but
then you can expand them to get as many
additional random bits as you want okay
so this doesn't even need a quantum
computer it can be done with current
technology although by current well to
really do it honestly you should use the
loophole free bail violations which you
know I only been achieved a couple years
ago and are not so easy alright
on the other hand you know you you know
maybe this doesn't work so well for
getting randomness over the Internet
because you know if you're just
downloading these numbers from NIST or
something well how do you know that
Alice and Bob were incommunicado right
how do you know that the devices were
separated in fact there is a thing
called the NIST randomness beacon that
gives the world 512 fresh random bits
every minute okay and you can go there
and apparently they are partly being
generated using Bell experiments right
now but the devices are not separated
nearly far enough as as we would need
for cryptographic security okay but you
know even if they were how would you
know
okay so now you know the new idea is
well you could get certified randomness
by using quantum supremacy experiments
including on this devices okay and so
you know the idea is you know we start
with a small seed on our classical
computer then we pseudo randomly expand
it to this much larger set of challenges
like a bunch of challenge circuits the
classical skeptic your classical let's
say client submits these challenge
circuits one at a time to the quantum
computer and you know the quantum
computer has to return samples from the
output distributions of each of these
circuits and the key argument that we
make is reasonably that well look you
know a quantum computer can do this of
course it can sample the output
distributions of these circuits but
if it is doing it fast then under
plausible complexity assumptions it can
only do it by sampling right there is no
deterministic algorithm you know even
with a quantum computer that will
generate plausible looking samples from
this distribution and do it fast right
and so this is a type of statement that
again if you grant me a strong enough
complexity assumption that I could
bennett that then I can prove such a
statement okay so the upside is this
requires only a single device so you
know good for you know doing over the
Internet and it's very well-suited to
Niska devices because basically as soon
as you have sampling based quantum
supremacy then you can also do this
right the technological requirement for
doing this is nothing additional to just
doing sampling based quantum supremacy
at all okay but you know we do need
hardness assumptions we do need initial
seed randomness and a big downside of
this scheme is that the classical
verification again you have to check
that the hog problem is being solved and
that takes two to the end time
classically which is well you know let's
say we want n to be 50 or something like
that
okay so you know we could you know get
private randomness we could get public
randomness some people might complain
well if the challenges are pseudo random
then we must have a pseudo-random
generator that we already believe in and
if we have that well then who cares
about getting true randomness right it's
like a it seems circular okay but
there's a few nice advantages that we
get for example forward secrecy even if
the PRG were to be broken in the future
as long as it's not broken now as long
as the quantum computer can't
distinguish the challenges from random
challenges right now then the random
bits that it gives us will still be fine
still be random okay also even the seed
can be public and yet the random bits
that we get out can be private okay and
the random bits are sort of demonstrably
fresh they were not known to anyone even
to the quantum compute
before it started receiving the
challenges okay so the basic protocol
well I sort of already sketched it you
know classical client generates and
qubit quantum circuits pseudo randomly
mimicking random ensemble for each T you
know client sends the TF circuit to the
server demands back a response SMT in a
very short time in the honest case the
response is just a list of samples from
this output distribution then the client
picks a small number of random
iterations again using its small random
seed and for each of them it checks
whether you know you know the hog
problem is being solved and if it's
being solved then it takes these all the
outputs from the server and it feeds
them into a randomness extractor which
is just a classical tool for taking a
bunch of bits with some entropy in them
and getting a string which is you know a
constant fraction as long but which is
nearly perfectly random okay for example
the GU V extractor okay and the main
result basically says that under some
suitable hardness assumptions that I
won't have time to go into that you know
that this works that it sort of
generates actually order of n new bits
of what's called min entropy in every
round that you that you do this min
entropy being this thing here okay the
heart you know it's with some effort one
can show this for any one round that
much harder part is to show that the
randomness actually accumulates from one
round to the next so I wanted to mention
that there is a very you know different
approach to getting certified randomness
from a quantum computer in a beautiful
recent paper by V Cooper Kirksey at all
I think all five of these people are in
Berkeley right now although only four of
them are in the room and so so so what
they have is a way to generate certified
random bits with a quantum computer
assuming the quantum hardness of
breaking lattice based cryptography and
I would go over their scheme if I had
time
unfortunately I don't maybe there will
be a talk about it later but but you
know it's it's a beautiful scheme but it
does you know and it gets a huge
advantage over my scheme which would
they actually give a polynomial-time
classical algorithm to verify the
results of the thing right I'm not able
to get that with my approach the
advantage of my approach is that you can
do it with a near-term device you know
whereas this one seems to require you
know at least on the order of a thousand
cubits and you know probably some sort
of error correction if you were to
implement it okay so there are many
exciting future directions
can we get quantum supremacy and
certified randomness under more standard
and less boutique complexity assumptions
can we get poly-time classical
verification of random bits and Niska
implement ability you know at the same
time in the same scheme can we get more
and more certified random bits by just
sampling with the same quantum circuit
over and over that would have huge
advantages in terms of the bit rate and
it would remove the need for the
pseudo-random generator but I'm unable
to prove the security of this okay you
know and then what about adversary's
that are even entangled with the quantum
computer ok so conclusions we might be
close to you know quantum supremacy
experiments we can say non-trivial
things about the hardness of simulating
them classically we'd like to be able to
say more certified randomness generation
is possibly the most plausible
application at least that I can think of
of very near-term quantum computers the
application actually requires sampling
problems right a problem with a definite
answer like factoring is useless for
this purpose we can not only can we do
it with you know fifty to seventy cubits
we don't want more than that right and
we can fully exploit sort of whatever
degrees of freedom are in the hardware
we have so I feel like with this
application all the weaknesses of
sampling based quantum supremacy
experiments somehow get can
verted into strengths all right let me
stop there thank you and so in the
generating random number yeah yeah comes
from seeing if the some random selection
of your random bits actually passes this
hrg chassis's yeah that's right
don't you need to actually classically
sample from the distribution to come up
with this bestest or can you get em sir
yeah well so again I assume that you
have a small number of seed random bits
okay we you use the seed for three
purposes one is to generate the
challenges one is to choose which
challenges to verify and the third is
that you need a seed to do the
randomness extractor okay so you need a
small random seed to get the thing
started but then once you have that this
scheme can give you an exponential
expansion in the number of random bits
that you have right
okay it's always very simple give our
calculations we take about let's say a
hundred thousand data points um yep and
then we have to run through a hundred
thousand points to get the probability
in in a few days or weeks or something
around forty-eighters hmm Alibaba did
they only gonna compute one yeah one
it's a lot smaller than a hundred
thousand so you can have a much bigger
though yeah there's nothing to do with
the experiment yep okay III I do agree
one is smaller than a hundred thousand
by a constant factor we can you know I I
mean at least one author of the paper is
here so maybe in the discussion this
afternoon we can yeah Greg yes
so this is actually a general interest
for evaluating tensor networks right
just for this thing okay right yep
probably and now I quit but you said it
so trade off and usually suggest a trade
off curves yeah
well I did I did I did we at least
verbally I told you what the curve looks
like okay I said for you start with the
Schroedinger algorithm for every having
of memory usage multiply the running
time by a factor of date BD being the
depth I told you yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah
[Applause]